no
buongiorno a tutti
il mio desiderio è che tutti possano
fare un gioco perché desidero questo
torniamo un po indietro nel tempo più o
meno alla fine degli anni sessanta era
un periodo molto particolare dal punto
di vista soprattutto della tecnologia
perché le persone
l'uomo da pochi anni era sbarcato sulla
luna c'era la corsa allo spazio c'era il
fascino della fantascienza i primi
computer che arrivavano e come tutti i
bambini quando ero piccolo volevo fare
l'astronauta
volevo esplorare di questi nuovi mondi e
poi dopo poco tempo ho scoperto che
c'era qualcos'altro che mi affascinava
tremendamente e che erano queste cose
qua che erano i primi videogiochi che
vedevo nelle nei bar sotto casa e che
spesso cercano di giocare anche se ero
molto piccolo magari in sei anni o
qualcosa del genere non arriva neanche
allo schermo devo salire su una sedia
rossa giusto una sede ricercato perché
mi piaceva perché l'interessato mi
affascinava queste scie colorate allora
prodotte da un oscilloscopio poi sono si
sono evolute sempre sempre di più però
queste prime shell colorate erano con
una porta d'ingresso in questi mondi e
poi c'erano film come come tron della
disney che per la prima volta aveva
parlato di questi moniti tra l'altro
forse il primo film che parlava della
figura del game designer che allora non
esisteva neanche nessuno ne parlava però
questi questi film raccontavano quello
che succedeva dietro quegli schermi in
qualche modo raccontavano che cosa c'era
come funziona ma è quello che mi
affascinava moltissimo e così come come
tanti bambini
ho iniziato a chiedere ai miei genitori
che vi comprassero un computer
questo è il sinclair spectrum è stato il
mio primo computer sono particolarmente
affezionato anche se oggi ho in testa
una cosa che a svariati ordini di
grandezza più potente di questo affare
però questo affare mi ha insegnato non
ero neanche dieci anni però mi ha
insegnato a provare a fare qualcosa era
uno strumento che mi permetteva in
qualche modo di sbloccare quello che
c'era dallo schermo passare dall'altra
parte e creare qualcosa e allora creato
il mio primo gioco di cui per motivi
tecnici non posso farvi vedere
un'immagine ma intanto non è
estremamente interessante a un gioco
fatto da un bambino che non aveva
neanche dieci anni era un gioco si ninja
perché allora i ninja erano interessanti
qualche quanto lo spazio e questo primo
gioco mi ha insegnato un sacco mi ha
insegnato che potevo utilizzare questi
strumenti come strumento creativo
poi c'erano anche cosa può più
tradizionali perché non c'era mica solo
la tecnologia
dopo qualche anno se ne arrivata ad
angelo sembra year stan johnsen dragons
è un gioco che ha fatto ha fatto epoca
un gioco di ruolo
cosa vuoi dire un capriolo gioco in cui
le persone interpretano in questo caso
personaggi di un mondo fantasy ma liberi
e lì per ore
e una persona crea il mondo che sta
dietro a questa avventura che gli altri
giocatori sperimentano e e in qualche
modo alla raccontano frati vere e questa
cosa mi affascinava moltissimo
partendo da quello che avevo fatto prima
la possibilità con solo carta e penna di
inventare dei mondi e di trascinare
dentro delle persone che conoscevo mi
affascinava in maniera incredibile
e in effetti i giochi sono proprio
questo sono modi di viaggiare nello
spazio nei termini sono delle macchine
che ci permettono di provare emozioni
sono dei sistemi che ci permettono di
creare emozioni e questa cosa delle
emozioni
per me è estremamente importante e forse
la mia visione più importante da game
designer per che cosa è successo che nel
corso del tempo fare giochi è diventato
sempre più difficile è diventato un
operazione sempre più complessa con
investimenti sempre più alti adesso
siamo investimenti che ormai hanno
superato quelli più film di hollywood un
gioco oggi costa tantissimo questo è una
parte del team che ha sviluppato
assassin's creed che uno dei giochi che
sono più conosciuti forse in questo
periodo quindi capite che non era più il
periodo in cui una persona da sola si
poteva mettere lì e fare qualcosa o
forse no giacometo diceva che i film il
cinema sarebbe diventata un'arte
soltanto quando i materiali per produrlo
sarebbero diventati costosi come carta e
penna
cosa voleva dire con questo volevo
parlare di democratizzazione voleva
parlare del fatto che una forma adatte è
una forma d'arte soltanto quando è a
disposizione di tutti quando tutti tutte
le persone possono in teoria prendere
degli strumenti e fare qualcosa
esprimersi e questo per me è importante
perché per me i giochi sono ci sono nato
in mezzo e sono in forma d'arte e voglio
che siano una forma d'arte
però come abbiamo visto prima team di
tante tante persone
questo è in contrasto con il fatto di
diventare una vera espressione artistica
ma dicevo o forse no perché
parallelamente a questo si è sviluppata
una serie di strumenti che sono in grado
di permettere a persone che sanno
pochissimo anche di programmazione di
creare il loro gioco
pino riassunti quattro sono di diversi
livelli di difficoltà alcuni richiedono
un pochino più
di capacità e di curva di apprendimento
altre invece sono estremamente immediati
sono importanti perché sono alcuni degli
strumenti con cui delle persone hanno
iniziato a fare giochi e questo è
interessante perché quando le persone
singole si mettono a fare i giochi
nascono delle cose straordinarie per
esempio nasce un senso di comunità
questa foto è presa da una gang che
cos'è una grigia è un una tre giorni 2 3
giorni dipende dal dal formato in cui
delle persone si mettono d anno il tema
prefissato e fanno un gioco questa che
in jam però ancora più particolare
perché questa legge si è svolta in un
treno che parte da chicago e arriva a
san francisco per la game developer
conference che elemento più importante
del settore
qui dentro ci sono si è sviluppata una
comunità di persone che per 72 ore
durante un viaggio ha creato il suo
gioco e allora quando gioca diventavano
proprietà personale di espressione di
una persona si possono nascono delle
cose interessanti per esempio di giochi
come autobiografia
questa l'immagine presa da ma inizi ma
inizia un gioco che è stato fatto da una
sviluppatrice americana che si chiama
metri bravis
metti price è una seria patrich e
transgender e da quella che gli
americani chiamano mixed race fa parte
di un gruppo razziale ben definito che
cosa succede a metti bryce prende un
motore per fare giochi e crea una cosa
che racconti la sua giornata quotidiana
l'aifa in giro e le persone non sanno
che appellativo darle perché e
transgender le persone di colore
la trattano come se fosse bianca perché
non è esatto
di colore le persone bianche la trattano
come se fosse di colore
tutti questi piccoli incidenti della
vita quotidiana sono raccontati
splendidamente in questo semplice gioco
e fanno sì che tutte le persone si
possono mettere per un momento nei suoi
panni e capire che cosa vuol dire essere
una persona come vecchi bryce un altro
gioco sempre autobiografico è sibillina
freeman qui ci addentriamo in una
sottocultura che è quella del mondo dei
giochi online in si bem mina freeman
racconta la storia di un innamoramento
di una storia d'amore che parte dal
avere condiviso uno spazio di gioco
online pdl anche metal se volete è
insita il tutto il gioco viene giocato
attraverso la simulazione dello schermo
del computer quindi esattamente quello
che si vede quando si gioca online
oppure i giochi possono diventare
qualcosa di più
ancora posso diventare un modo per
esprimere il proprio pensiero la propria
visione del mondo
questa papers crisi più casco in peeters
crif i giocatori assumono i panni di un
agente della dogana un agente della
dogana però di un paese di uno stato
totalitario non ben definito ma non è
questo l'importante
quello che è importante è che nei
processi che questa persona tutti i
giorni affronta nel decidere chi deve
entrare nel paese e chi non può entrare
e inasprirsi ogni giorno di più delle
regole che servono per entrare in questo
paese
lucas bove riesce a dipingere il
rapporto che c'è tra i paesi moderni
democratici con il problema
dell'immigrazione e in maniera anche un
po preoccupante dimostra come non sono
poi così diversi da quelli di uno stato
totalitario un altro gioco molto
interessante su questa linea sulla linea
del espressione della visione del mondo
e wings of oreja del milanese saltara
che racconta la storia di un viaggio
nell'italia degli anni 70 che parte da
roma e arriva fino alla francia tutto
lungo la via aurelia e che è un mix tra
un gioco di guida un gioco narrativo nel
quale c'è questo personaggio nella che
di volta in volta fa il viaggio insieme
alla sua amica e di volta in volta
raccoglie degli autostoppisti partecipa
a gare automobilistiche buttate lì al
momento fa diverse cose e racconta uno
spaccato della storia italiana degli
anni settanta in una maniera che è molto
critica della storia italiana di oggi
quindi racconta i rapporti tra stato e
chiesa raccorda la sua condizione delle
donne racconta come viene trattata la
diversità e ci mostra come dagli anni 70
ad oggi su molti temi non abbiamo fatto
tutta la strada che pensiamo di avere
foto oppure possono essere giochi che
portano avanti il nostro la nostra
identità culturale
questo e 20 mesi anche questo di un duo
italiano che si chiama lui hanno
riesling loro sono milanesi mi hanno
fatto questo gioco raccontando venti
storie diverse della resistenza però non
sono 20 storia della resistenza in
generale sono venti storie legate al
paese di sesto san giovanni che il paese
da qui loro venivano e quindi sono
riusciti non solo a raccontare ea
preservare una memoria storica molto
importante per il nostro paese ma anche
a collegarlo a un posto molto specifico
del mondo oppure fascia farsi ma di
bahrami un ragazzo iraniano che ha preso
il concesso del tappeto e la cultura che
è legata all'arte
due tappeti dell'iran e l'ha riportata
in un ciò in un gioco che è un
sostanzialmente puzzle game c'è un gioco
in cui bisogna combinare degli elementi
nel modo corretto che però mostra quella
che è la sua identità culturale
e allora quello che dico è che noi
abbiamo un territorio inesplorato
vastissimo che i giochi come medium
espressivo hanno la capacità di
esplorare e questo territorio
inesplorato fa sì che noi come singole
persone se iniziamo a fare giochi può
essere piano piano scoperto e possiamo
scoprire delle cose interessanti perché
i giochi non sono soltanto modi di fare
vedere delle cose ma sono dei motori per
l'empatia i giochi permettono di
metterti per un po di tempo nei panni di
qualcun altro e di vivere le stesse
esperienze e allora se sono motori per
l'empatia forse è il caso che noi
cominciamo accenderli questi motori
perché molto importante e li possiamo
accendere non pensando di creare un
gioco per poi venderlo non
necessariamente molti dei giochi che
avete visto prima sono gratuiti alcuni
commerciali altri noti non è importante
come quando le persone aprono loro
taccuino e scrivono dentro i loro
pensieri non tutti vogliono fare
letteratura non è importante questo però
quello che importante che si faccia
quello che importante che questo questa
forma espressiva venga utilizzata e
venga portata avanti perché ogni singola
persona che lo fa migliora tutto il
panorama
il presidente americano barack obama una
volta ha detto non comprate un
videogioco fatene 1 ora lui si riferiva
al discorso puramente tecnologico
oggi noi abbiamo in mano degli strumenti
estremamente potenti lo ha detto prima
telefonini ai file quello che volete ma
molto spesso siamo soltanto utilizzatori
passibili questi strumenti non sappiamo
cosa c'è
non abbiamo quella curiosità che avevo
avuto io di vedere cosa c'era oltre lo
schermo e allora presidente obama dice
no i bambini devono imparare a
programmare perché devono capire che
questi sono strumenti creativi
straordinari e imparare usarli però c'è
un'altra cosa di cui tenere conto che
forse ancora più importante del discorso
strettamente tecnologico ed è fatto che
i giochi vari giochi è un'attività
estremamente umana e che ci rende
persone migliori esseri umani migliori
perché se noi facciamo giochi e
giochiamo giochi conosciamo meglio le
altre persone ci mettiamo a magliano i
panni delle altre persone e molte delle
dei conflitti che nascono dalle nostre
differenze possono essere appianati
grazie